un nuevo día de temor aquí en la palma
las coladas de lava enorme que veis
detrás de mí se han formado hace 24
horas y continúan avanzando hacia el mar
la plataforma de lava que se ha creado
en el océano alcanza ahora más de 28
hectáreas según los científicos la
calidad del aire empeora un poco pero
sigue respirable y sin riesgo para las
personas los daños materiales aquí en
esta parte de la isla son enormes hay
más de 1000 edificios que han sido
destruidos estuvimos hablando hoy con
varias personas que viven aquí y nos
hablaron de un espectáculo monstruoso
este espectáculo monstruoso lo van a
seguir viendo porque según los expertos
la erupción podría continuar más de 80
días el presidente del gobierno pedro
sánchez va a venir este domingo para ver
la situación aquí